how's it going everybody it's Warren I
always love the few months after movie
gets released because the directors the
writers the producers go on tour and
they do a ton of interviews about the
movie which is exactly what is happening
right now we are getting a ton of
information about Avengers in game
through multiple interviews and we're
learning what went into these movies the
meaning behind some things and even some
stories that didn't end up in the movie
which is what we're going to talk about
today there was a story arc that was
written in the script for Avengers in
game for Captain America that did not
end up being in the movie and it's
something that a lot of fans were asking
about after the movie came out so I'll
break that down in this video real quick
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe when I hit 400,000 subscribers
I'm doing a giveaway picking three
winners to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection so be
sure to subscribe and hit that thumbs up
button so in a recent interview with
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
they were talking about a character that
was not included in Avengers in game
that many fans were asking about and
that is agent 13 / Sharon Carter she
played a pretty big role in Captain
America Civil War and a romance even
started between her and Steve Rogers so
where exactly was she during the events
of Avengers infinity war and Avengers in
game did she get snapped according to
the writers no not at all according to
the writers an early version of the
script had Sharon Carter and Steve
Rogers living together continuing their
romance but it wasn't going well here's
what writer Stephen McFeely had to say
about the story but again cast your mind
back to Infinity Ward anything that was
not about the stones fan OHS we're in
trouble
this propulsive narrative got jettisoned
we tried to sue up all sorts of things
we had first drafts where Steve was
living with Sharon Carter and it wasn't
going very well so an early version of
the script Sharon Carter and Steve
Rogers were still in a relationship
together and it was taken as far as them
living together as far as the problems
that they had there could have been a
lot of problems especially because
Captain America was essentially wanted
by the whole entire world and it was
sharing Carter's job really to find him
but ultimately this did not end up in
the movie which is really good because
that would have made the ending kind of
awkward Steve would have went from
living with Sharon come
Steve would have went from living with
Sharon Carter to ending up Mary
her Aunt Peggy Carter so ultimately this
was cut for that reason but we have not
seen the last of agent 13 it has been
confirmed that she will return in the
Falcon and Winter Soldier series and
we're told that in this series Bucky is
going to be going on dates so perhaps
Sharon Carter is one of the people that
he dates which is kind of awkward as
well but Captain America went back in
time and married Peggy Carter so all is
well I guess so let me know what you
think about this alternate story for
Captain America where he was living with
Sharon Carter in a relationship would
you have liked to see this on screen or
are you glad they cut it out and let me
know how excited you are for the Falcon
and Winter Soldier series coming to
Disney Plus let me know in the comments
down below and again a reminder about my
giveaway be sure to subscribe at the
400,000 subscriber mark I'm going to be
picking not one but three winners and
each will get to choose one item from
the Marvel Legends series collection all
you have to do to enter is be subscribed
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
relations to your desperation to save
the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
you're a number